germany's political parties have begun
exploratory talks to form a new
government that looks set to be a
three-way coalition two of the smaller
parties the greens and the pro-business
fdp have already held a first round of
joint talks now greens leaders are
meeting for their own inner party talks
to discuss the strategy for further
negotiations
autumn colors in berlin red yellow and
green the shades of the parties sounding
out a coalition
red for the spd green for the greens and
yellow for the pro-business ftp in a
so-called traffic light coalition
surveys say the majority of germans
favor that kind of alliance
chanan byram from the green party's left
wing has serious reservations
climate protection won't happen on its
own
how can we do that with a party that
says the market will sort things out i
don't know maybe i'm not creative enough
to imagine the compromises
of fantasy
green party leaders are walking a fine
line the greens and the free democrats
are worlds apart politically
tough compromises lie ahead that could
be hard to sell to the base
hey this canvas
we can create something new
wake up germany
something new can emerge from this
that's cool
if we go into the talks with this spirit
we can release new energy
that's what we want
in berlin many greens have doubts about
joining forces with the liberals but
after 16 years in opposition they're
also eager to get back into the fray
what motivates us is the desire to
finally get things done our time as an
opposition party is over
the base knows that we are now entering
negotiations and we have to make
compromises but that doesn't mean we're
selling out
now the greens must decide which
promises they could sacrifice
chanan bairam is wary of paying too high
a price
it's been revealed i was elected to
advocate on social issues particularly
on rents
we also need to bridge the gap between
rich and poor
we need to pay special attention to
these issues
but when i compare the party platforms
i just don't see how it could work with
the fdp
a traffic light alliance in germany will
demand a lot from all involved but it
could also come tumbling down
just like the autumn leaves do
eventually
we're here with chem ud samia a member
of parliament for the greens and former
parley leader uh mr uttamia how
optimistic are you about talks with the
fdp being successful
well it's first the liberals but we also
have the social democrats and in a
third round the christian democrats i'm
quite optimistic because this time
everybody wants success everybody is
aware about the responsibility we're the
fourth largest economy
other
countries are looking at germany how
fast we will build the new government
i'm quite optimistic that we managed to
have a government before christmas
in terms of finding common ground it
might be more difficult with the free
democrats when then with the spd for
example what uh differences do you think
might be a problem in finding agreement
of course we have uh big differences but
on the other side we also have some
things that we have in common we want to
modernize the country germany is lacking
behind regarding digitalization
they have a different approach with the
climate protection but they also accept
you know that we have to do something
and germany has to move ahead so maybe
we can find some common ground there as
well and on foreign policy
uh this is also very important vis-a-vis
the social democrats both parties are
against north stream too both parties
have a more critical view vis-a-vis mr
putin so that could be also some area
where we could move together ahead
and there's been some criticism of the
fact that the green team going into the
negotiation is not diverse is not very
diverse as someone uh like you with a
migration background what do you respond
and how do you see this criticism
well i don't criticize my party board i
was
myself a party leader and
i promised myself uh when i one day hand
over to the next leaders that i'm not
going to be the guy who is criticizing
them
so if i have to tell them anything i do
that directly not vis-a-vis media but
trust me
the
cabinet members will be much more
diverse than this team trust me on that
many thanks
joining us from the greens party
conference in berlin is our political
correspondent julia saldelli julia are
the greens any closer to agreeing to a
way forward
here at this party conference today the
greens have approved the team that will
go into the negotiations in the next few
days and weeks that's already an
important step and they have also
defined the guiding principles of what
they want to achieve we've heard
party co-leaders anna lena berbak and
nikola habek say they do want to be a
part of the next government and they do
want to put forward an important
ambitious
plan to fight climate change now they
are aware that to end up in a government
they will have to find an agreement with
the
business friendly fdp this is something
they are very much aware of and they are
ready to go into these talks and are
positive about the outcome
what about the overall political picture
in germany now where do things stand
so at the moment the social democrats
the center-left social democrats who
have come in first in the election are
sort of leading uh the talks and uh
going ahead and talking to
both the greens and the fdp and it seems
like a majority of germans are in favor
of this kind of three-party solution for
the next government but uh the
conservatives who have suffered an
important loss in the election who have
come in second still haven't really
given up they are also talking to the
smaller king maker parties and they'll
be ready to uh come into play again if
the coalition talks with the social
democrats do end up failing
all right political correspondent julia
saldelli speaking to us from the greens
party conference in berlin thanks very
much